-We all love our pets.
And every pet owner thinks
that their pet is the best.
And I wanted to see
if that was true.
So, it's time for "Why Is
Your Pet Better Than Me?"
Here we go.
-♪ Why is your pet
better than me? ♪
♪ Better than me ♪
Alright.
Let's meet our first pet.
Hello.
Welcome to the show.
What is your name,
and where you from?
Hello.
-Hi, Jimmy.
My name's Christa.
My husband, Michael,
is behind me.
He's our ringmaster.
-Hi, Michael.
-And this is Roo.
-Roo, welcome to the show.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Christa, why is -- Is it Roo?
Is that the dog's name, Roo?
-That's her name, Roo.
-Her name.
Hi, Roo.
You're very cute.
She's ignoring me right now.
She's giving me full side eye.
Look -- That's right.
Aw, no.
-Her attention fully on
what she's going to show you
right now, actually.
-Yeah, Roo.
What does Roo do?
Why is your pet better than me?
-Roo is better than you
because she can keep balloons
up in the air
using only her nose.
-Oh, yeah.
Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is so good.
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Roo!
Oh, my gosh.
I could watch that all day long!
Oh, my gosh!
Good job, Roo!
It's like she can't stop it!
It's unbelievable.
Love it, Roo!
Oh, my God, watch it all day.
Thank you.
Great job.
Thank you
for coming on the show.
You're awesome.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
-Thanks for having me.
-Let's meet our next pet.
Hello. What is your name,
and where you from?
-My name is Roy Portner
from Abington, Pennsylvania.
Right outside of Philadelphia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Outside of Philly.
We love it.
Thank you.
Roy, welcome to the show.
Now, who do you have
there with you?
-I have Marcus.
-Hi, Marcus.
Hi, Marcus.
And what does Marcus do?
Why is he better than me?
-Marcus is better than you
because he can howl
the "Werewolves of London"
by Warren Zevon.
-That's one of my jams.
I love Warren Zevon.
"Werewolves of London."
So that song comes on
and he howls to it?
-Yes, sir.
Everyday, after I'm done
working, I'm ready to walk him.
[ Light laughter ]
-All right, I got to here this.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
[ "Werewolves of London" plays ]
-Sing it.
[ Dog howling ]
-Yes!
My dude!
Yes!
Yeah.
Marcus, on his own terms.
Great job.
-Took a while,
but we got him going.
-Great job, Marcus!
Thank you for that.
Alright.
Let's meet our last pet.
Hello. What is your name,
and where are you from?
-I'm Brad Friesen
from Vancouver, Canada.
-Oh, Vancouver.
Beautiful.
We love Vancouver.
And what is your dog's name?
-This is Mister Bentley.
-Oh, Mister Bentley.
Mister Bentley -- Why is
Mister Bentley better than me?
-Well, I've seen some
of your dance battles,
and you're not the best
moonwalker.
And that's one of Bentley's
specialties.
-I mean, yeah, I've done
the moonwalk a bunch of times,
one of my go-to dances.
But Mister Bentley can moonwalk?
I don't think I've ever
seen a dog moonwalk.
-Are you ready?
Go get it.
Get your ball.
Yeah, he's got to go
get his stick.
Get it.
You get it.
Ready?
Get it.
You get it.
Got to come.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'll take it!
We got it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about,
a moonwalking dog.
Thank you for being on the show.
Good job, Mister Bentley,
good job.
And great job to all
of our talented pets.
If you have a pet that you think
is better than me,
I want to see it.
Go to tonight-show.com/
whyisyourpetbetterthanme
to submit a video of your pet.